twice on Sunday Donald Trump told
audiences at two different rallies that
electing Hillary Clinton could lead to
an inflow of 650 million immigrants and
refugees in just one week to the United
States now if you're familiar with
anything you probably realized that
that's mathematically impossible and
politically ludicrous but that did not
stop Donald Trump from saying at
multiple times first in Colorado Donald
Trump said but she wants open borders
and we have a quote to show you here but
she wants open borders she wants open
borders we could have 600 million people
pour into our country think of it once
you have open borders like that you
don't have a country anymore well okay
maybe in Greeley Colorado Trump said it
and then someone got to him and said oh
you know that doesn't really make any
sense but no when he got to New Mexico
he said it again and I will show you
that quote where Donald Trump said she
wants to let people just pour in you
could have 650 million people pour in
and we do nothing about it think of it
that's what could happen you triple the
size of our country in one week I have
to hand it to Donald Trump at least he
seems to understand the number of people
that live in this country correctly
asserting that going from 340 million if
you add 650 to that you would have a
close to a billion people at least if we
have to find the silver lining in this
insanity Pat and I know we've got a dig
pretty damn deep to find one Trump knows
how what the population of the u.s. is
which is nice for a presidential
candidate yeah that's always good and it
seems like Hillary Clinton's policies on
immigration would just be an extension
of Obama's which means more people going
out than coming in and an increase in
deportations net outflow of immigrants
to Mexico relatively modest increases to
the number of refugees that come in but
the numbers just make no sense with 650
million if everyone from South America
came to the u.s. in a week that would be
422 million people add everybody from
Central America and we're at almost 600
million be
add Canada that gets us to 633 million
people we would still not even be at the
number Donald Trump is talking about and
he's talking about in a week which by
the way would require border crossings
to operate at 40 times capacity the
airport system of the United States
couldn't handle it
there aren't enough rental cars in the
United States to accommodate that number
of people there aren't enough houses the
Census Bureau estimates that there are
17 million empty housing units and we've
got about five million hotel rooms in
the country this is not a matter of
politics this is not a matter of policy
it's not even really a matter of math
it's a matter of basic common sense and
it is baffling that anybody is going to
vote for this guy never mind the reality
but somewhere between forty and fifty
two percent of the electorate is
probably going to end up voting for
Donald Trump on November 8th that is
very very disturbing this doesn't pass
the sniff test this doesn't pass the
most basic BS test and it's
fear-mongering it's fear-mongering and
at this point it's fear-mongering to the
lowest of the lowest information voter
because who on this earth never mind
in the United States would believe that
in a week six hundred and fifty million
people are going to come into the u.s.
from other countries it just makes
absolutely no sense as many in our
audience know I am a big fan of the
Mediterranean diet and as a result I
don't eat that much chicken and steak
etc but this has made me even pickier
when I do have chicken or steak and for
the last month I've had my Omaha Steaks
family grill pack which comes with a
bunch of really great stuff filet mignon
top sirloin all beef meatballs steak
burgers all sorts of really great stuff
for $49.99 and when I want one I take it
out of the freezer the previous day
defrost it in the fridge and then the
next day I'm ready to have my steak and
you know as I've talked about because I
am an advocate of the Mediterranean diet
and I'm not a steak and chicken
everyday-- type of guy when I do have
those things
I want them to be good and having the
fresh frozen Omaha Steaks in my freezer
ready to go when I want them has been
absolutely fantastic and for my
listeners and viewers Omaha Steaks is
offering the entire family grill pack
which includes everything I mentioned
and more for $49.99 this is a really big
savings and you can go to Omaha Steaks
comm and put in my coupon code Pakman PA
KMA n in the search bar and then you can
add the family grill pack to your cart
at a discount
don't miss the deal I've been enjoying
it and I think you will too